somehow in movies filled with
larger-than-life super-powered
characters the totally regular dude at
the bow and arrow still managed to
become a fan favorite it's pretty
unlikely when you think about it that
Clint Barton better known by his super
heroic alias of Hawkeye would ever
become so popular but that's exactly
what happened and his upcoming return to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
Avengers endgame is generating tons of
hype among the MCU s most ardent fans
who cares about that old beat Thanos and
resurrect half the universe's population
thing Hawkeye is back and he's got a new
outfit none of this makes sense but
sometimes what a character wears in a
movie is nearly as important as what the
character actually does and Hawkeye is
no different that's why it's interesting
to imagine an alternate universe where
Hawkeye had a different look on the big
screen for that thought exercise we turn
to our exclusive interview with Charlie
when former head of visual development
at Marvel Studios who drops knowledge
about the direction he and his team
almost went when designing Hawkeye's
threads believe it or not Hawkeye
originally started in the mast
adventuring game not because he wanted
to make a difference in the world
not because of some kind of trauma that
forced him into a life of archery and
not because he was bitten by a
radioactive arrow no it was because he
was working at a carnival sideshow and
got jealous of how much people loved
Iron Man that's seriously it now with
that kind of origin story one in which a
guy decides to be a costumed crime
fighter purely out of spite
it's no surprise that the first version
of the outfit he put together leaves a
lot to be desired that original outfit
eventually morphed into the more or less
classic blue and purple costume that the
character is best known for but let's be
real
neither of these outfits ever had any
hope of making it onto the big screen in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe one of
Hawkeye's most influential changes
occurred in 2002 when Mark Millar and
Brian hitch launched the Ultimates sort
of a modern version of the original
Avengers team ultimate Hawkeye wore a
sort of tactical espionage outfit in a
pair of shades
there isn't anything particularly iconic
or even memorable about it but it does
look much more realistic and far less
ridiculous than his traditional
comic-book purple Charlie when explained
that when designing Hawkeye's cinematic
appear
and Thor and Avengers the art from the
first two Ultimates runs penciled by
Brian hitch served as an overall
inspiration well I know we definitely
referenced a lot of Brian hitches work
on Ultimates one explained that the work
he was doing for Avengers was a
departure from the comic books we all
grew up reading even though the movies
of the MCU are well known for how close
they stuck to the source material the
kind of stories I was telling was
definitely a lot more grown-up stories
right not the kind that we grew up with
so were the costumes is a little bit
more gritty a little bit more earthy in
Avengers I was creating the hawkeye's
for something that was more urban it's
not like he was in this whole superhero
world at all I mean he's a normal guy
about a year after the Avengers hit
theaters another long-awaited superhero
project started gathering steam the
Netflix series daredevil starring
Charlie Cox and while when didn't
actually work on the daredevil project
it seems that great minds really do
think alike according to when he thought
his approach to Clint Barton cinematic
design managed to find its way on screen
anyway just in the form of Netflix's
take on Matt Murdock so in a way it's
like maybe I was envisioning him a
little bit more of what eventually
became of daredevil for the Netflix
series much later that's kind of the
feel that I was thinking about when I
was doing that version of Hawkeye
crucial to wenn's approach he said for
the qualities that definitely make
Hawkeye less super and more human you
know I wanted to make sure I portrayed a
version that was more urban and more
about a family guy who is Hawkeye as a
person that vision of the character
eventually appeared along with Hawkeye's
wife and kids by the time Avengers age
of Ultron hit theaters in 2015 funnily
enough that movie featured a costume
design that hewed even more closely to
Hawkeye's classic non ultimate
comic-book design throughout the
character's existence not only has Clint
Barton changed outfits with some
regularity
he's even changed identities in the 70s
he got mixed up with Hank Pym sighs
changing gizmos and took on the identity
of Goliath and in the 2000s Hawkeye took
on yet another Super alias
Ronen a black clad martial artist who's
as good at using a sword as he has a bow
and arrow meanwhile the MC use version
of Hawkeye seems to have been fully
reinvented yet again the trailers for
2019 s Avengers end game revealed that
Clint Barton seems to have shed his
Hawkeye identity in favor of what
appears to be the cinematic debut of the
Ronin outfit while we don't have much
information about what may have prompted
the character's latest change of clothes
it goes without saying that whens work
designing a grounded realistic version
of Clint Barton undoubtedly had a huge
influence on the hot guys we've grown to
know and love check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
exclusive looper videos with Charlie
when about the creation of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]